ciao a tutti oggi faremo uno scherzo a
berlino in questo caso non c'è fuori che
sta giocando in giardino
gli faremo uno scritto molto particolare
vedremo anche in quanto e coraggioso
praticamente abbiamo un ragno gigante
finto se decorate vitale mi hai baciato
e questo scherzetto mentre io dormivo e
se non l'avete visto poi andata avete
prodotto questo video vi faccio vedere
il ragno che guardate un po questo è il
ragno finto ed è anche telecomandato
quindi sono super curioso di vedere come
reagirà merlino una volta che lo vedrà e
una volta che lo vedrà a muoversi
soprattutto tra l'altro questo ragno si
attacca anche alle pareti
ora vi faccia subito vedere come
funziona allora lo metto prima per verrà
qua dentro c'è il telecomando
quindi io potrò decidere dove farlo
andare a chen diavolo
c'è chi gli occhietti rossi marino
l'ingegnere rincorre gli effetti e poi
vediamo
sembra rincorrere quest'orario doveva
passare secondo voi come secondo me
merlino inizialmente si spaventerà per
il rumore di questo ragnetto di quegli
occhietti rossi ma poi cercherà subito
di morderlo non di moro dal nuovo di
masticare un insetto che mi fa male sì è
vero però secondo me continuerà comunque
a mordicchiarlo comunque a cercarlo di
metterlo in bocca per assaporarlo il
vero che invece si giocherà e penserà
che è uno dei suoi giochi così parlò di
reagire a rincorrere un ragnetto allora
vediamo invece sulla parete come va
[Musica]
oddio quello che funziona ancora
io ci vado vediamo se funziona meno male
allora ora facciamo entrare berlino
prima lo lascerò un fermo al centro
della stanza vetta muoverlo vediamo come
reagisce e poi inizierò a farlo muovere
noi vediamo diversi insieme arriva se lo
ricorda vediamo se ne accorge
chiaramente non si sa se ha paura o no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
berlino berlino che stai vedendo ciao a
tutti oddio
sembra divertirsi tanto tu
[Risate]
berlino voti fa in seguito dal ragno
[Musica]
dice che c'è un amico pazzo non voglio
così lo magno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un buon gusto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
k
si sta scatenando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
poverino
penso che andando lì lo metto
nell'armadio vediamo come reagisce
[Musica]
comodi cosa che mi siedo qui vieni 3
tesoro che un team che tocca julio ora
vediamo come reagisce asiatica goria
jagger
[Musica]
grazie
pagando ogni tanto
papà
[Applauso]
[Musica]
credo un po l'ho preso e se tutto perché
abituato che si chiede quando ti devo
dare qualcosa che ci sono io è molto più
coraggioso
avete visto che scappa di melo per
domani vediamo lasciamoglielo prendere
vediamo cosa fa vuoi che ti nuova alta
da provocare sì forse se lo vuole
mangiare pure che si muova berlino che
cattiveria che ci guardano
[Musica]
berlino
mi sa che questa è la fine del ragno e
via ricorrendo ai 10 secondi illustro
muri cucciolotto io mi piace terzi a
stare in braccio e rimane buono buono in
braccio tra poco non potremo più
prenderlo in braccio però perché sarà
gigante allora è riuscito a rompere il
ragno almeno pensano su se si è
scaricato ma penso che si sia rotto e
anche spezzato una zampina però devo
dire che si è divertito molto perché
stava sempre scodinzolando si è agitato
un po all'inizio perché non capiva cosa
era ma poi ha subito capito ho pensato
che fosse uno dei suoi giochini però più
divertenti perché si muovono pure e
scappano
qui in via è stato super divertente
questo scherzo davvero sono contenta che
si sia divertito tanto e lo vuole ancora
prendere
e che si fa per dire poi in grembo come
ogni volta che mi spiega venite a
cercando il ragno maragliano c'è più la
nasco perché sennò se lo avrebbe
mangiato spaccato fi per come
pilota da detto dopo aver giocato così
tanto in cui stanco ora viviamo le
crocchette che l'eco esisterà ancora più
queste dopo aver lanciato allora nessuno
è super contenti che a berlino ha fatto
un po di attività ospite di vera casa
tanto così gli attesi nei commenti che
altri video volete vedere non 3 o con
merlino scrivete tutti i consigli nei
commenti 4 castellino e pubblicare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite le polarità